foreign
[Music]
this is Sky News at 10 our top story a
dangerous collision between the United
States and Russia a Kremlin fighter jet
hits an American unmanned drone causing
it to crash into the Black Sea this
incident demonstrates a lack of
competence in addition to being unsafe
and unprofessional
this incident
lack of competence in addition to being
unsafe and unprofessional the words
there of the Pentagon also tonight big
offers for parents and on pensions the
chancellor hopes for a bounce in the
polls with his back to work budget
jailed for eight and a half years the 22
year old woman who concocted an
elaborate lie about being groomed and
abused by a non-existent Asian gang
I've had my landlord call me a rapist
I've had people across the road called
me a rapist I've had neighbors call me a
rapist you know just mud sticks
[Applause]
[Music]
banking stocks rebound after the
collapse of Silicon Valley Bank the U.S
justice department orders an
investigation after the turmoil plus the
lasting Legacy of The Fosbury Flop
tributes to the Revolutionary high
jumper
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's in our
press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
thank you
hello there good evening the United
States summoned the Russian ambassador
to Washington this afternoon after
military officials said a Kremlin
fighter jet hit one of its surveillance
drones in international airspace over
the Black Sea a pentagon official
described it as Reckless and
unprofessional saying two Russian Jets
dumped fuel on the Drone before clipping
one of its propellers Russia has denied
this with the two countries giving very
different versions of what happened
at approximately 703 am Central European
Time one of the Russian su-27 aircraft
struck the propeller of the MQ-9 causing
U.S forces to have to bring the MQ-9
down in international waters
several times before the Collision the
su-27s dump fuel on and flew in front of
the MQ-9 in a reckless and
unprofessional manner this incident
demonstrates a lack of competence in
addition to being unsafe and
unprofessional U.S and Allied aircraft
will continue to operate in
international airspace and we call on
the Russians to conduct themselves
professionally and safely you'll see
that miss Catherine dotford has conveyed
her concerns and United States concerns
regarding this incident and I hope that
you have seen today
remarks by Mr Kirby and
part parole of State Department on this
issue nothing new
well it's not the first time that
Russian aircraft have intercepted
American drones over the Black Sea which
borders Russia turkey and Ukraine but it
was the first time Ward led to a crash
which led to the Ambassador being
summoned let's get more than our
security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes joins us now from Westminster and
Deborah this is the closest encounter
between the US and Russia since this war
started how seriously is this incident
being taken
very seriously right to the highest
level the president of the United States
is aware of it the most senior U.S
general in NATO the Saka has has told
all NATO member states about this this
incident is a stark reminder of the risk
of escalation into direct confrontation
between two nuclear-armed states that
the war in Ukraine poses around
Ukraine's Skies including over the Black
Sea there are an increasing number of
NATO aircraft including British aircraft
and of course Russian Jets and that is
why you have this increased risk of of
an encounter and on this occasion an
encounter that has resulted in the loss
of a highly sophisticated American drone
it's not a small aircraft it has a
wingspan of 20 meters a length of 11
meters it's now in the sea and you can
only expect that Russian vessels in that
sea there aren't American vessels known
to be there we'll be trying to hone in
and pick up the remains of the aircraft
and see what it can glean from them the
Americans will have done all they can to
wipe any sensitive information off the
jet of off the Drone sorry but yes it's
a stark reminder of the risk of
escalation and of course tonight it
seems that both sides do not want this
to escalate further it seems that this
was not a deliberate attempt by the
Russian jet to down the Drone but the
action was Reckless according to the
Americans it was unsafe this these these
Russian jets are accused of dumping fuel
on the American drone apparently trying
to Blind it the Russians saying that
that drone was flying close to Crimea
which Russia claims as its own it really
does underline the tensions in this
region which are only going to continue
as long as this conflict remains
Deborah with that update thank you
understands that child care for working
parents in England is to be extended to
cover one and two-year-olds in
tomorrow's budget the chancellor is
expected to offer the financial help as
part of a package of measures to get
more people back into the workforce
Jeremy Hunt is also tipped to raise the
total amount of how much people can hold
in their pensions without it being taxed
well other measures expected include
support for energy bills to be extended
for three months there will be pressure
on the government to increase public
sector pay amid ongoing strike action
and with pensions as we said it's
understood the government could increase
the lifetime allowance and cap on
tax-free contributions here's our Deputy
political editor Sam coats
how do you reignite the British economy
right gentlemen what we're doing today
is you're currently your fitting task at
this Factory in Walsall they're
manufacturing the workers of tomorrow
Labor shortages are holding back
companies across the country I think
Marx what is currently surfaced grinding
to get the Downs of Tolerance but here
they train hundreds of Engineers young
and old the skills they need to fill the
gaps local businesses are are Furious
really that we've got this skill
shortages over recent years especially
during the pandemic you saw a lot of
people in the main redundant furloughed
or realize there were such a point in
life where they could actually exit
engineering manufacturing and retire
so what we're trying to do here is
Achieve by reskilling them quickly to
come back into the sector
one of the big drivers of the UK labor
shortage is a rise in early retirement
the chancellor says he wants to get the
over 50s off the golf course and back
into jobs tomorrow's budget will raise
the tax-free pension allowance to 1.8
million pounds a financial carrot to
keep the already well off in work for
those enjoying a round of golf here it
could be a hard sell I don't think
anything would have made me delay
retirement I think there's a lot of
people who would probably like to retire
early and I think I would call myself
living in the Golden Age where I
actually could if you've paid until
pension for all those years and the way
that pensions are calculated it doesn't
make sense to stay on for a lot of
people you know most of us here are
probably in a fairly privileged position
but you know to a lot of people that
could make some changes like the
pensions changes possible in the budget
that will probably keep some people at
work but at the moment you know there
may be maybe retire
budget without a huge War chest to spend
so why choose this measure there are
huge differences inside the conservative
party about economics perhaps bigger
than any other policy area
the party simultaneously seems to want
lower taxes and higher growth and lower
borrowing and to spend money on leveling
up which is why it looks like tomorrow
Rishi sunac will go for the path of
political least resistance allowing
pensioners to take more money tax-free
effectively helping the Tory party base
a lot of money but not helping huge
numbers of people the proposed big
increase in the total amount you can
save into your pension pot tax-free will
make a big difference to some
individuals mainly richer households but
it won't increase the number of workers
overall significantly in fact some
people may retire earlier as a result of
it the things that will make more
difference are very welcome changes to
child care support within Universal
Credit and there are very big changes
being proposed in the disability benefit
system but those will take years to
implement
this will be a budget of relatively
small numbers but there will be an extra
4 billion pounds which the government
claims will fund 30 hours of child care
a week for one and two-year-olds parents
and providers hope the Chancellor's sums
add up Sam coat Sky News
well the chancellor will be hoping that
his budget will boost growth in the
economy and help avoid a recession our
data and economics editor at Conway has
been taking a closer look at how the
government plans to balance the books
the budget Jeremy Hunt's first budget
and of course the big question is what
are we going to hear about first of all
of course there will be growth what
happens to economic growth the state of
the economy is there going to be a
recession this is what the obr the
office for Budget responsibility they
did just formal forecasts this is what
they were saying last time around look
at 2023 the Year we're in at the moment
1.4 down so both going down everyone
getting less well off that's a recession
what might happen this time around let's
add some bars on with the average of
independent forecasters and look the Red
Bar in 2023 it's still down but less bad
than it was before minus 0.6 that's why
independent forecasters say but look
over there on the far right hand side
weaker growth according to those
forecasters than the obr was expecting
last time around that really matters and
I'll show you why if we plug that into
what happens with borrowing how much the
government is spending and and getting
in taxes the difference between that is
borrowing borrowing has been pretty high
recently very high indeed the
government's concerned about that 140
billion in the next next year what
happens to that if you assume we are
going to have that kind of change in the
growth forecast well here's what might
happen look those red bars go down so
stronger growth in the short run weaker
growth in the in the long run though
I'll show you why that matters in a
second on top of that lower interest
rates so lower debt interest costs for
the government look at the red bars they
go down a little bit more so as a result
of that and again energy costs because
energy costs are lower than expected
that means it doesn't have to spend as
much on the energy price guarantee might
have a bit more money to make it a
little bit more attractive for
households too again those red bars
going down and actually toss it all up
and you're talking about growth
borrowing coming in about 30 maybe 40
billion pounds less than was forecast
last time around that's a really big
deal and potentially means the
chancellor has some money for a
short-term giveaway why do I say short
term look at the right hand side look at
those two bars on the far right hand
side 20 27 28 actually the red bar is
higher so more borrowing in the future
meaning he can't just splurge and expect
a splurge forever necessarily if he
wants to keep these bars going down
which of course he does
but then there's a question about what
does that mean for us what does it mean
for public services here's Public
Service spending how much has increased
or indeed decreased over the last few
years you can see austerity there but
this goes all the way back to the 80s
and over that 40-year period the average
at which it was going up issue about 1.8
a year more recently it did improve so
look at this on on the right hand side
it went up by about 2.8 percent a year
in recent years was expected in the
future well only about one percent so
not quite austerity necessarily but
really low increases by historical
standards question is whether Chancellor
does anything about that about public
sector pay or indeed about corporation
tax well the many other issues coming up
we'll find out more in the budget
well let's speak now to Sam Coates who
is outside number 11 Downing Street so
what is the broad thinking behind this
budget then Sam
the thing that Rishi sunak and Jeremy
Hunt want to do in what will be their
first budget is to tackle one particular
problem which is one in other countries
the number of people in work has been
going up since the pandemic in the UK
it's been going down and there are now
almost a million more what's known as
economically inactive people in Britain
since pre-coronavirus and they're going
to look at that question from kind of at
every angle so it's changes to the
pensioner allowance that you adjust the
tax free allowance that you were just
hearing about possibly raising the
retirement age looking again at
disability benefits net uh the way that
those kick in and tonight's eye-catching
announcement the one that you just heard
about which is 33 hours of child care
for the parents of one and two-year-old
children now you have to look at the
fine detail of that the scheme for three
and four-year-olds often gets criticized
by nurseries because the government
don't put in enough money I know they're
aware of that issue inside number 11 so
we'll have to see uh whether they deal
with that but Anna I wonder whether or
not tomorrow for many people the budget
is the second most important economic
event of the day because millions of
people in London are going to struggle
to get into work because of the tube
strike millions of parents are not going
to be able to work at all because their
children will be at home because
teachers are out on strike for the next
couple of days there is in tomorrow's
budget clearly money to play with but
not it seems for anything decisive on
public sector pay there have been a few
more positive noises in recent weeks but
nothing decisive and every time there's
a strike that's a hit to growth that
means less revenue and that actually
hurts the economy is this a completely
joined up strategy that's the question
at number 11. thank you well coming up
our political editor Beth Rigby visits
the residents of Wickham
I've had to change my hours at work
because of child care costs so I can't
afford to work full-time anymore
and test the temperature of those
awaiting the Chancellor's new budget
a 22 year old woman from Cumbria who
pretended she'd been abused by an Asian
grooming Gang has been sentenced to
eight and a half years in prison for
perverting the course of Justice Eleanor
Williams from Barrow and furnace
concocted what a judge described as
complete fiction she even hit herself in
the face with a hammer to look as though
she'd been attacked three of the men she
falsely accused attempted suicide and
her made-up story sparked Community
tensions across the area our home editor
Jason Farrell has this report
Eleanor Williams buying a hammer in
Tesco which a jury found she used to
injure herself in an effort to support
lies that she'd been raped and battered
by multiple men
there is no explanation for why the
defendant would commit these offenses
she has gone to extraordinary lengths to
create false accusations including
causing ourselves significant injury
after her sentencing today some of her
victims spoke out I've had my landlord
call me a rapist I've had people across
the road called me a rapist I've had
neighbors call me a rare Christian or
just mud sticks like everyone looks at
you everyone knows who you are you know
what I mean like because I was named in
the paper for a such serious sexual
offense what I didn't do then we worked
like picked out so persecution it's a
sense of persecution that don't play it
in the 21st century and it was just
we're going for the Asians and it was a
full-on targeted or towards the Asians
Eleanor Williams claims about an alleged
Asian grooming gang which she posted on
Facebook changed the peaceful Seaside
town of Barrow
there were hate crimes protests erupted
in town while police couldn't reveal
they had evidence she was lying for
example this footage of her checking
into a hotel in Blackpool on her own at
a time she claimed she was being raped
in a number of different properties I've
had cases where people told lies but
never ever to this extent and I do
believe that if she hadn't been charged
in this instance
it just wouldn't have stopped Miss
Williams was found to have set up fake
social media accounts to make it appear
she was receiving messages from abusers
and speaking about it for the first time
Elena's sister Lucy says sometimes her
sister did Doctor things on her phone
but since she filmed these messages
coming in of guns and knives and
believes at least one man not named as a
victim in the case was intimidating her
it grabbed her outside of the takeaway
started pulling her arm he was like come
on we'll go in did you see that yeah and
she was like no I'm going with my sister
and his face he was so angry with her
and and she did come home with me and
then the next weekend she came back
black and blue like worse than we'd ever
seen it was Lucy who took the photos of
the injuries that Eleanor posted on
Facebook that a pathologist would later
say in court were consistent with being
self-inflicted but Lucy doesn't accept
that
do you think there's any chance
theoretically that on that occasion she
hurt herself no in order to create more
impact no
very few other people have seen those
injuries firsthand yeah you have yeah
you were there
just describe them I've never seen
anything like it
Eleanor's family except she lied about
things such as claims that she was
trafficked abroad but for her mother
Alison it doesn't make the verdict any
less painful
and how did you feel when that guilty
verdict came through heartbroken were
you there we were in the court
describe it to me I can't
still
can't take it now really
it just doesn't feel real
what do you think her motives were for
for making up the things that she she
did makeup I just believed that she was
trying to get people to listen to her
in a statement reading Court Miss
Williams says she was sorry for mistakes
she'd made but she didn't admit guilt
the men who faced false allegations say
that is a hollow apology
Jason Farrell Sky News
let's return to the war in Ukraine now
and President Putin making workers at a
helicopter Factory in southern Siberia
said again that the conflict represents
a fight for the very existence of Russia
his comments came as the Ukrainian
president warned that his country's
future was being decided in a bitter
fight in the East against Russian forces
the city of bakmut has become the focus
of that bitter fight with thousands
reported dead on both sides for Ukraine
it is a symbolic stronghold and for
Russia Victory there would Mark the
first major breakthrough in months
meanwhile casualties have also been
reported in the nearby city of kramatosk
following multiple Russian missile
strikes our chief correspondent Stuart
Ramsey and his team have spoken to
Ukrainian soldiers in chromatosk and in
nearby kostiansky nifka and sent this
report
another Russian missile strike on a
residential neighborhood in eastern
Ukraine at least one person was killed
as it hit at breakfast time
resident gingerly picked her way through
the rubble looking for anything she can
save the contents of her home strewn
across the street
slowly the most elderly were helped from
The Battered buildings
Bendix moving in to dress wounds and
inspect her injuries her hands were
nastily burned
even as we filmed the air raid sirens
started again crematosk is regularly
attacked but it's no less of a shock to
those who still live here
[Music]
other family now have been bombed out of
their apartment
it's a big explosion here you can see
these buildings
big explosion in in into this section
here that's all collapsed and and over
here where's the the main strike point
was point of the matter is
virtually nowhere in this area is safe
anymore sometimes are much worse than
others we're relatively long way from
the front lines here but everywhere is
in range and every day people are losing
their homes and pretty much everything
the Ukrainian defense of the East and in
particular the city of bakmut is now the
center of the government's strategy the
whole area is now an enormous military
zone troops piling in to join the back
move defense
and this is what it looks like inside
they're fighting house to house
these Ukrainian soldiers are under
attack they filmed their defense
the RPG firing Soldier moving from side
to side of the home putting down fire
casualty rates here are horrendous for
both sides
a team of soldiers are greeted by
volunteers who have brought them some
supplies they just got out of back mood
to make this Supply run it's Grim inside
they say
everybody
[Music]
more units are being brought in from all
over the country to fight will Ukraine
win I asked
[Music]
same deceptive
because it was so many soldiers there as
well I think the Russians
numberable
military analysts are questioning the
Ukrainian tactic of slugging it out with
the Russians but President zelenski says
it's a must
civilians who've decided to stay can
only wait and watch and hope that soon
it comes to an end
Stuart Ramsey Sky News eastern Ukraine
the US Department of Justice is to open
an investigation into the collapse of
Silicon Valley Bank after President Joe
Biden promised to do whatever is needed
to protect the banking system U.S
banking stocks have recovered some of
their losses after nearly 190 billion
dollars were wiped off their value since
svb became insolvent last Friday a U.S
correspondent Mark Stone reports now
from the New York Stock Exchange
in the heart of the financial World on
the floor of the New York Stock Exchange
the opening bell and a rally of the
stock market good news for the moment
[Music]
a place driven by Vibes by Risk by
Instinct and haunted by the 2008 crash
had bet that after one heck of a weekend
the chance of contagion was low
yeah I think at this point right now I
think the nervousness level has gone
down significantly I think coming into
Monday with the s p Futures Trading as
high as they were with that fear of
weight you know we're seeing an inverse
relation as to the headlines versus what
the Market's reaction is I think we've
washed out some of that but again we've
all lived this before and we're waiting
for like what is that next headline and
a week is a long time in this world a
day is a long time an hour is a long
time in this world things can pivot very
quickly as you've seen the decision by
President Biden to guarantee all the
deposits of all the customers of the
three failed Banks was as remarkable as
it was drastic broadly it calmed nerves
shares in other mid-sized Banks were
down but then rallied
there are many economic factors at play
here and only so many levers available
in Washington to attempt to provide
stability controlling inflation is key
and yes prices are continuing to rise
the main control lever is interest rates
officials were looking at whether to
raise them more aggressively to slow
inflation
but these Niche banks failed in part
because of interest rates they could not
cope with Silicon Valley Banks customers
clearly there is huge relief from
Biden's decision I'm so grateful for the
U.S government for stepping in because
small and medium-sized businesses like
ours would have no access to Capital
overnight and I feel like we are really
just swept up in this panic in this
frenzy over the last few days when
we had absolutely nothing to do with it
all of this raises a few key questions
first was the government spooked into
its drastic action by a tech sector
which fanned fears of a systemic problem
secondly why wasn't the government
monitoring unusual Banks like this for
any potential wrongdoing third what now
for inflation interest rates maybe they
cannot come down but if they don't then
what does that mean for inflation for us
all the metaphors right themselves but
the bubble that would impact us all has
not burst the inflation bubble well
that's proving harder to pop Mark Stone
Sky News that the stock exchange in New
York
well as many voters struggle with the
cost of living tomorrow's budget could
be a big test for the government to
convince people they have a handle on
the economy our political editor Beth
Rigby has been to Wickham in
buckinghamshire to see if people in the
safe tour receipt still have confidence
in the party
Wickham in buckinghamshire atori Shire
of the south east and for so long a safe
Suburban seat
but this a constituency where the Creed
of conservatism could be losing
believers
I went to observe a focus group
conducted by pollsters yougov to see how
people hear in Wycombe feel about the
policies and priorities of politicians
back in Westminster there's no real
long-term strategy for investment and
it's just caused all these problems
problems which are costing the public
tomorrow's budget very much on their
minds I've had to change my hours at
work because of child care costs so I
can't afford to work full-time anymore I
came off a fixed tariff in January but
I've been on for two years you know the
jump was you know quite immense an
immense time in the country's political
history this a group of floating voters
but they agree on one thing hands up if
you think we need a change of government
actually
actually trust issues lack of plans
you know all of that is what what I see
whenever I hear conservative I trusted
them a long time and then you get so
many mistakes you're just like you know
what
mistakes of the past now uncertainty
about the present and Rishi soon act 2.
I don't know why I don't trust him but I
don't
um
disingenuous yes but the opposition
party not yet winning them over if the
labor party
wants to
uh consolidate its lead in the polls
it's got to start developing a sense of
what it is it's not a reason to vote for
labor and there's a reason to vote not
or not vote for the conservative yeah
a general election a while off yet but
the mood of Voters here offer a taster
of the challenges for both parties as
labor tries to gain ground and the
Tories try to hold them off Beth Rigby
Sky News Wycombe
now you might not know his name or
remember him competing but dick Fosbury
has left a legacy that few in sport can
match he revolutionized the high jump
with his unconventional technique which
became known as The Fosbury Flop can't
say it and inspired thousands of
athletes and many Beyond The World of
Sport either Bennett hasmore
it was quite literally a leap into the
unknown that flew in the face of
convention and flopped into the history
books dick fosbrie's eponymous technique
won him the Olympic gold medal in 1968
at a time when this was the norm
he couldn't have been more different
to demonstrate The Fosbury Flop we
sought out Dalton Grant look at this
I don't know if it fits me
it's me still a former Commonwealth high
jump champion
first the run-up then the leap backwards
and head first
for me how I felt I felt comfortable it
was like flying over your you know in
the air so once you went over and you
lean off the curve and you hit that that
take off that sweet spot you use your
free fire shoulder tie arms and then you
elevate the momentum from the ground off
the curve tilts you into that rainbow
take over the bar and then you just
you're just flying it seems like you're
up there for so long
before the Flop was the scissor kick and
also the western roll techniques that
now seem hard to believe existed
part of what led to fosbury's new
jumping style was the introduction of
this
the crash mat which gave him something
soft to land on but at the time his new
technique was still considered hugely
dangerous with some warning it would
lead to a Spate of broken necks
his determination to reach New Heights
has left a legacy well beyond sport
most people have heard dick Fosbury or
you might use the phrase The Fosbury
Flop technique before former high jumper
turned motivational speaker Steve Smith
is among the many in the corporate world
who use him as a study in Innovation
well I think I've used a call from dick
Fosbury pretty much uh every week for
maybe the last 15 years so he uses a
metaphor for Innovation he's used as a
matter for doing things differently but
he also uses a metaphor for challenging
those who can't adapt to new ways of
working
his new way of working did eventually
become the norm at first seen as a freak
Show The Fosbury Flop was soon the
future Ivor Bennett Sky News